and finally new rule if you get up every
day and try to make Donald Trump's
ludicrous and dangerous pronouncements
sound normal and sane you are an enabler
twenty years from now when your kids ask
you over a glass of Soylent Green what
did you do during the Trump years daddy
you don't want your answer to be my job
was to go on TV and pretend Trump didn't
say what everybody just heard himself
[Applause]
that is an enabler and that word is not
a compliment we've heard it a lot with
celebrities Elvis had his Memphis mafia
Michael Jackson had a doctor who never
said gee Mike your nose just fell off
again maybe cut back on the plastic
surgery
Bill Cosby could not have pulled off
Bill Cosby could not have pulled off 40
years of oh let's call it extreme dating
without various underlings who funneled
women his way and paid them off to say
nothing of the guy who supplied the
horse tranquilizers and never once said
Wow bill that is one nervous horse you
have there
one of the great enablers of fiction is
max the sycophantic manservant - the
delusional Norma Desmond in the classic
movie Sunset Boulevard now a Broadway
show and especially timely because it's
about an aging unstable drama queen
who is able to maintain a fantasy world
because even though Norma Desmond is
pure around the bend batshit nuts
like I say timely
[Applause]
she has max there and he keeps the world
were real world far out of sight in the
plot Norma Desmond is a faded movie
Queen a silent film star of the 1920s
but now she hasn't worked in 30 years
but she still thinks she's big
because max max goes into the basement
every night and writes fake fan letters
to fool her into thinking the people
still love her is that really any
different than this guy pretending to
have intelligence that backs up with his
mad boss tweeted at 3:00 in the morning
or the way Trump's handlers keep sending
him to rallies where he only has to see
the people who tell him he's doing great
just like it says on his hat I'm sure
last week when Trump's health care bill
went down in flames he was surrounded by
enablers who all nodded when he said I'm
still Bigley it's Congress that got
small
Trump has nothing but Max's around him
did you know that Devon Nunez once
defended Trump by saying I think a lot
of things he says you guys sometimes
take literally excuse me we shouldn't
take the President of the United States
literally right he's a poet when he
nukes Finland it's a metaphor super
Christian Mike Pence seen here cringing
from an air kiss because you don't know
how far simplest can jump Mike Pence
conveniently forgot the famous line from
the Bible thou shalt not grab a [ __ ]
when he gave Trump the cover he needed
to survive [ __ ] gate has been Christian
Jeff Sessions who when asked if he
thought uninvited groping was sexual
assault said I don't know it's not clear
how that would occur here Jeff it really
depends on the circumstance like like
for example if you saw a [ __ ] about to
fall off a cliff you'd want to be able
to grab it without political correctness
getting in the way
enablers Sean Spicer and Kellyanne
Conway are the West wing's Flowers in
the Attic a lunatic locked them up and
now they're crazy too this was the
largest audience to ever witness an
inauguration period both in person and
around the globe well that's pretty good
ass-kissing but Reince Priebus
you could do better catch you well I
think the president's a hundred percent
correct and he hits the bull's eye in
that tweet like he often does exactly
because who can picture Trump and not
think accuracy is fleeting and have you
seen this psycho who will not only
blindly repeat anything Trump says no
matter how crazy we know for a fact you
have massive numbers of non-citizens
registered to vote in this country but
is such an ass licker he licks the ass
of people who lick Trump's ass I do when
I say the tongue Spicer as always is a
hundred percent correct and that what he
said is true and important and I agree
with it you know without these
professional liars and deniers
there's no Trump it takes a village to
help a man-child stay in power
and the excuse I'm just doing my job
is starting to sound an awful lot like I
was just following orders